et le sénat demain ça va être un espace
de vraie liberté à l'endroit que la
semblait avoir de l'exigence des
propositions où on n'est pas dans le
dogmatisme et je dois dire que 10 c'est
ce que voulait dire ici un jeu mais
vraiment de goûter pour ça mais on le
sait les verts de l'assemblée d'or
est-ce que l'assemblée parce que c'est
pas un mot facile godillots peut-être un
mois je fais confiance aux collègues de
l'assemblée nationale ce film est ici il
ya un espace de liberté
il ya un espace d'initiative c'est vrai
que nous ne sommes jamais aligné nous
sommes jamais en fils
souvenez-vous du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy la majorité ici était
majoritairement dans la majorité
présidentielle de l'époque et pourtant
sur nombre de sujets là exprimé sa
liberté ne nous entendait que le sénat
exprime encore plus sa singularité la
majorité sénatoriale n'est pas
automatiquement calquée sur la majorité
présidentielle c'est un point important
de même que l'opposition au sénat
s'appelle souvent groupes minoritaires
plutôt groupe d'opposition et moi je
suis très attentif aux droits de
l'opposition savate d'ailleurs à ce
sujet à l'assemblée nationale puisque
nous aurons des groupes d'opposition à
gauche comme au centre et à droite qui
seront on le sait beaucoup plus réduit
qu'on ne l'imaginait les droits de
l'opposition
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel vous